e
I open the work session on the special
committee on the Family Division of the
circuit
court
and as you know and for the record we
had presumably finished our work last
couple of three months ago we looked at
four different items and uh came to some
good conclusions we enjoyed buyin from
the Jud Judiciary in part because they
helped us along the way or we help them
and the speaker wondered if we were done
would we submit our final report and I
suggested to the speaker that it be the
interim report and that we stay open as
a special committee until the end of
this legislative term or at least
October
31st and the reason for that is we I
assume there might just be some items
that we hadn't thought of that somebody
else would think of down the road that
might be appropriate for us to look at
and in the event four things
emerged uh two things had been assigned
to the special committee on the
DCF that the speaker's office and I
think rightly so decided were better
placed with us second uh the the third
item is I I don't know how it came to us
but the third item is on the agenda here
and the fourth one was submitted by
representative
Greg so what I plan on doing and you've
all been sent emails and you all have
hard copy in front of you is to go
through each one of these
items and see if there is sufficient
interest to form a subcommittee
uh we do not have all of our members
here but if we as the group of people
who are present think there's
Merit uh I will communicate then with
those who are not here and see if they
are
interested and if there is sufficient
interest we will make this a
subcommittee I will appoint a chair to
that
subcomittee and of course
91a rules apply uh uh you may not have a
meeting of a majority of the members of
the
subcommittee unless it is advertised in
the uh
calendar uh held in the public place
which rules out this building for July
and
August also you cannot have a private
meeting with more than a majority of
people to discuss it anywhere
else you can however
have a one-on-one discussion with
another member of the subcommittee if it
is a large subcommittee perhaps it could
even be three people discussed but it
has to be more than
50% you can bring have a conversation
any of the members of the subcommittee
with people in
agencies special interest groups people
you know who care about this our
committee researcher once we know know
what subcommittees will be constituted
we'll start the process of doing the
research that's needed to see what other
states do on this what current law might
process I jumped the gun on an opening
remark uh representative Joe
Alexander uh republican from the
Judiciary Comm committee is uh uh no
longer a member of this and has been
replaced by republican from the
Judiciary Committee uh boob
Linn the
first um
possibility is to research title
four of the Social Security Act this is
all on your handouts here specific to
the state of New
Hampshire how much is collected how why
where does it go representative Jess
Edwards formerly of Health Human
Services and elderly Affairs committee
presently chairman of division three of
Finance uh wants to be on board as a
consultant and this this is an important
thing to him research title for the
Social Security Act specific to the
state of New Hampshire how much is
collected how why where does it go and
so on any thoughts on item one
one Vice chair thank you very much Mr
chairman I need help um and I'm turning
to you for help can you help me
understand what the relationship
is between title four of the Social
Security Act specific to the state of
New
Hampshire and the fact Family Division
Court I yield to anybody who knows
anything about this
um yes uh repres uh yeah sorry for the
krian good morning Aon krian general
counsel for the judicial branch um title
four includes a number of subtitles
typically we think of a through e and
they include things like temporary
assistance
families and uh foster care Grants the
one that involves the court system the
most is subsection D C is in Charlie D
has in Delta okay thank you um which
involves child support payments um under
title Ford states are eligible to
receive uh reimbursement for up to 66%
of the time that's spent on child
support obligations typically connected
to the tanif and Medicare programs and
that's been implemented in New Hampshire
since the 1980s it's implemented in all
50 states that there is a reimbursement
for time the court spends on these which
every year varies how much money is
million any further questions for
attorney
krian yes oh no I don't have another
question for for um the representative
from the court I I do have a a question
um
again I'm quite
title for of the Social Security
Act
um I don't know why it would be this
committee that would be charged with
finding out how much is
collected uh and how and why and where
does it go um we have um the
LBA we have
HHS
um why would it be this committee that
would be the best
place to look into oh and we have in
terms of legislative Committees of
course we have Finance why would it be
this committee that we
would go to representative Lynn yeah you
know my understanding I may be
completely wrong on this but my
understanding and I
believe it was from discussions with
representative couta but I could be
wrong is that apparently there has been
some claim
that because of the federal funding that
is provided to the office of child
support enforcement
in DC in uh the Department of Health and
Human Services that that
somehow causes that office to be more
aggressive I guess is it would be the
the if I'm the right word more
aggressive than it should be in in in
enfor ing child support obligations that
that as I understand that's the claim um
I'm you know it's been quite a while
since I did Child Support Enforcement
stuff but when I was doing it it was the
D dcyf was getting I mean the Department
of Health and Human Services were
getting Federal funding for that I never
had any sense that that was causing DC
to act in some way that it wouldn't have
acted otherwise but you know maybe I'm
wrong on that that but anyway that's my
understanding of the claim I I have I'm
skeptical that there's anything to the
claim but that's what I understand the
claim to be but Mr chair if I could
follow up on that
even whether you're skeptical or not
about the
claim I don't think we have to uh reach
determination on that I think that this
is a matter that
belongs um elsewhere it belongs in
Health and Human Services
it belongs in um the legislative budget
analysis it belongs in uh
Finance
[Music]
um I
don't I I I don't see and no one has yet
said anything that would
indicate
why how much money is collected and from
whom and what belongs in the family
court and I won't I won't belabor the
issue it might just be that I'm a slow
learner but um and I wouldn't argue with
that I just don't say it belongs here
attorney krian I think I heard you
Court yes sir um in so far as title four
deals with tanif and Foster families it
is money that is going to DHHS it is
only child support uh funding that is
collected and reimburse to the court
system for those who work on those
issues we can get about 66 out of $100
for that time if we submit time logs to
DHHS who then submits them to the
federal government um it's it's a
not insignificant amount of money but
it's a small percentage of the overall
running budget of the Circuit Court um
and there is absolutely no impact on the
Judgment of Child Support referees or
judges that is both statutory and a
requirement of due process so would it
be your conclusion that there is some
narrowly focused warrant for this
committee to look at title 4
subd I don't want to weigh in on your
debate but I Ford would be the only part
in which the courts would have a role as
opposed to DHHS okay so yes
representative
ball thank you chairman parison I'm
sorry to keep raising my hand just a
clarification um
I believe that when we were originally
talking about this the concern that was
being brought forward to us was from um
people who came to
testify that they were not aware that
they did not have to participate in the
program and so they were participating
in a program where they actually didn't
need to they didn't they could have just
made payments on their own without going
through the program or am I I could be
mixing this up with something but that's
how I um that's how I believe people who
came testify said that they weren't
given the option not to participate and
that they were not aware that they had
that
option I'm not certain what that
individual person's circumstances are I
will say that if you are a TANF or
Medicaid recipient I I think that in
order to receive those benefits you
typically do have to go through this
program and that is the most frequent
user of it although there can be some
others that decide to use the process
because it can be more convenient for
them but those would be off topic to us
those are programs that are administered
long thank you Mr chairman um
so without being involved in
tanif um if my spouse and I agreed not
to go through this is that not to go
through uh the division of child
support is that historically with the
courts okayed or uh do they still
have you go through Child Support
Division
the title title 4D imposes certain
obligations on the court system to for
example block schedule all of the all of
the referrals through the Bureau of
Child Support Services but um the laws
in New Hampshire are not markedly
different outside that administrative
aspect of it so I I don't know that it
you would not be necessarily in that
block scheduling where you have multiple
Bureau of Child Support claims being
brought one one after the other but it
might not make a big difference to the
underlying case although I think if
you're if your non-cohabitating parent
is a TANF recipient then they have to
show that they've done their due
diligence to assign that claim over so
if if you're not participants in those
programs your the legal standards on
child support may still apply but you're
you're probably not going to be block
scheduled with one of these cases which
is multiple um Bureau of Child Support
Services claims one after the other okay
you based on what we've heard if there's
no further questions about whether a
very narrow subset of
this is an appropriate subject for this
uh Who present would like to serve on
such a
subcommittee uh representative katab has
already indicated to me she would like
to is there anyone else representative
know okay there's three and I will put
this question to the members who are not
present to see if there's anyone else
and based on that um we may or may not
uh constitute this as a
subcommittee uh stay tuned
item two also passed on to us from the
speaker's office originally this had
gone on to the special committee on DCF
but it was deemed more appropriate to
come to us and this is to address
potential ways to address perjury you
may remember both in some of you in
children and family law and all of us in
this committee uh except for
representative Lynn we had numbers of
people who uh alleged
uh opponents in various trials were
committing perjury and therefore the
judge was
remiss and not knowing that and dealing
with it
accordingly this question did come up a
lot um allegations we heard from numbers
of people were that person was lying and
I can prove
it well okay what should happen next if
somebody make makes that allegation to
what degree should Family Court be
required or strong strongly suggested to
go to the next step you believe there is
perjury we certainly want the whole
truth nothing but so what do we do uh
again attorney krian anything from
Judiciary that you might like to say I
know you're going to do a wonderful job
with whatever we come up with but uh
anything from your are
end my pleasure to be helpful to you if
I am I hope that I am um I can say for
for perjury it's of course a criminal
offense it has to be investigated and
prosecuted by the executive branch um I
have had by the which branch the
Executive Branch the that unimportant
branch that isn't here right now uh
isn't represented here watching they're
oh I'm sorry I think they certainly are
watching well I'll apologize later um
strike that from the record okay go
ahead thank you um so there's not a
major role for the court system of
course unless they hear the perjury case
later when it's brought for um a
criminal trial which would be in
Superior Court it's a class B felony
um I do certainly and and I'm sure you
do the same when you talk with
constituents if they feel as though they
have proofs that would meet the
Reasonable Doubt standard or that it
could be gathered to to make sure that
that's investigated I think the
tremendous difficulty that people have
and I understand why it is so stressful
is that they know what the person is
saying is false but it's difficult to
have proof that a jury would find
persuasive Beyond A Reasonable Doubt
particularly if it is one person's word
against another that's very difficult
thing for 12 unanimous strangers to say
who who's telling the truth and who's
not um the more you have in terms of
contradictory statements in terms of um
a person may be admitting to you in text
that they they got you in court today
things of that kind are things that the
jury can look at and consider um I did
um try to talk to a couple prosecutors
before coming because I knew this was a
subject you'd be looking at and they do
take perjury cases from time to time but
I can tell you that the impression that
I got and it matches with my own
experience when I used to charge
material false statement cases as a
federal prosecutor um juries have a high
standard uh they really don't want
someone who's just mistaken who just
misspoke uh typically the best evidence
that I had the most luck with as a
prosecutor was a person admitting and
writing or video that they had lied and
and at some point having an
understanding of why they had lied um
so it is a it is a challenge uh to meet
that Reasonable Doubt standard with a
jury and I'm sure that's a factor in the
the cases that County attorneys
investigate investigate and prosecute to
what degree does provable intentionality
play in perjury so it does pen but for
perjury it does have to be uh it does
have to be material uh so it does have
to have it potentially impacted the
outcome of the
proceeding um a statement that the
person does not believe to be true or
knew to be false in be required so it's
it is certainly not mistake inadvertent
uh
misr misremembering it has to be some
intentionality there that the person
wanted to mislead the FactFinder a
couple of people spoke to to me
privately and thought that
if these individuals said that is a lie
and I can prove it it's like the
proceedings must grind to a halt and
that issue must be addressed before it
could
continue and then put alongside that if
the judge uh concludes even if so it
does not materially affect the outcome
should the judge state that do the
judges state
that in general the the trial process is
intended to create that opportunity to
offer the relevant evidence and so it
might not be offered at that time with
that witness you might have a chance to
offer that relevant evidence later in
the trial it may it may not grind the
proceedings to a halt it may be that you
get that evidence in at a later time but
I think it's often the case these are
very tough cases these are the worst
thing that happens to most people um is
being divorced not seeing their children
as much as they were going to not living
in their family home anymore um that the
thing that they are very invested in and
that they they believe that their maybe
their former spouse their co-parent or
their child has lied about is not
something that would legally affect the
outcome of the proceedings and so if
that's the case the court may
say that that's a collateral issue
essentially that if someone has lied
they it's still within your purview to
bring it to the attention of law
enforcement it's still something that
you can report um but it may not be
something that would impact the
particular legal question which is being
adjudicated at that moment depending on
what that fact
is do you think that
perhaps
um a a greater statement of
clarification could be made by the judge
at such time so the person claiming the
other party was
perjuring uh would understand how the
process is working and not feel like the
person's just being waved off I know
that's something that that judges take
very seriously especially when you're
dealing with two self-represented
litigants is wanting to make sure that
they understand the process as much as
possible um and the exact way it
presents in each case is a little
different and a little individual each
time um what it is that they want to
discuss what is being adjudicated at
that moment um what evidence they want
the court to consider um so I think
that's something that judges take very
seriously is how in that individual
moment do you communicate with this
self-represented person and help them to
understand what's happening in that
proceeding but I'm I'm not sure even
those that do their best and try their
hardest bat a thousand and always um get
that through in the way that they hope
to and want to and I know it's something
we're always working on is better
communication with self-represented
litigant what I've tried to do
throughout the process of the special
court is address
the um excited testimony of numbers of
people who feel there's something bad
going on um
to take it what they're saying seriously
and if possible
give reasons why certain things are
being done the way they are um I'm I
believe some people when an explanation
is made would be you know unhappy it
went against them but understand it I
also know some people will never do that
no matter what you say but I want to
take those who are reasonable and with
an explanation say okay I get it uh so
what my question is is can we do
anything here to
improve uh what is being alleged with
the statement of perjury for those who
could come to understand why and I guess
so that I can kind of take that question
back is it that you're hearing from
constituents
that they're not understanding the role
that an accusation of perjury plays in a
family case because I can certainly we
are constantly training judges on what
are the common issues what are things
that you can do to communicate better we
have a an office that deals with
Community engagement where we
particularly look at issues with
self-represented litigant and how we can
handle them better um if there's a
common problem we definitely want to to
look into that what we can be doing
better and training judges on it this
could be uh one of the many sub chapters
of that wonderful book I know you guys
are working on that is given to anybody
who comes in uh prosay you know your day
in court with all of these questions
that arise where there's wonderful
explanations on them uh representative
ball thank you chairman
parison if I recall um correctly and I I
could be wrong um the people from the
public who came to testify before us the
concern they brought was specific to
falsified police reports in which the
person then acknowledged that they
falsified a police report against the
other spouse but then no perjury charges
were filed and I believe we even asked
um someone from the court and I can't
recall who or from one of the um
organizations uh departments how many
perjury charges have come out of family
court and I believe the answer was zero
in the last 10
years so I think what the Public's
concern is if someone falsifies a police
report what is the penalty because
according to law it's supposed to be you
get charged with perjury but if that's
not happening and we continue to have
people falsifying police reports in
order to put themselves in a better
position in the Family Court how do we
stop that what's if it's we don't want
to clog the courts up with a lot of
perjury charges but how do we get that
recognized within the family court that
it's unacceptable and that there there
has to be some accountability obviously
the children you can't you can't involve
the children in the
um that can't affect the um where the
children are going to be um located but
but there still has to be something how
do we stop that I think that's the
question I would like to know that's a
very good question and uh one one thing
I will say is perjury is one of a few
different charges in chapter uh 641 and
one of them is false report to law
enforcement um which is a misdemeanor so
it doesn't go before a jury typically I
think it's an uncategorized misdemeanor
so I think it would go to District uh
court and one thing I would say is um it
should be reported it should be reported
to law enforcement if that that has
happened
um it's difficult for the family court
as an adjudicatory body to give their
address that people want but if someone
has falsified a police report that is a
crime um and that is something that the
the police have the power to investigate
and the County attorneys have the power
to charge um it's unfortunate to hear
that that doesn't happen because it it
does seem as though you're he in cases
where that may have happened and we do
have a statute that looks to me like a
perfectly serviceable criminal statute
that covers that conduct um so I'm I'm
not sure where the breakdown is but I
would encourage litigant to to make that
report directly because there is a
criminal statute that covers that
conduct representative
Greg thank you it wasn't sure if you see
my hand down here I've learned to see
Hands represent I did one of her reaches
so I think it's also important to for us
to remember when we think about is this
something that's you know um something
that we should Pi up even though we have
people that say well this was falsified
against me or whatever that's that's
always very very relative and um truth
can be relative which I know people like
it to be black or white but what one
person sees in an instant is going to be
very different um I do know that there
are many people that lack insight into
their own behaviors and so they might
think that something has been falsified
but when you really dig into it it did
happen um that way so I'm not sure that
this something that we should really
look into we do know that there is
something for false police reporting
we've passed you know bills on um you
know blatant I guess uh to make it more
criminal if you have a a case of abuse
where you've determined abuse or
whatever but this is you know this is
just one of those very relative things
and I sat on that uh special committee
on DCF to and where we say we think oh
well if we make somebody take an oath
they're definitely going to tell the
truth or if we tell people you have to
tell the truth again that's not how that
works as a matter of fact I think that
the the study of people will tell you
that the more somebody uh says that
they're telling the truth it's usually
um the negative so this is all very very
relative and not something I don't think
over uh our history here as you know is
we haven't brought forth bills as a sub
as a committee but we have had dialogue
in
conversation and I I like how that's
been working um representative uh Lynn I
my guess is that you know a little bit
about
this um I yeah I probably do and I I
think um I guess I have two comments um
first
um in family law cases there are again
my experience goes back aways but I did
have fair amount of experience that
there are
it's not at all uncommon for one side or
the other to be claiming that the other
side is lying about
something actually proving that that's
the case is very difficult which why is
is
why um you know there are very very few
cases that are actually referred to the
to the uh executive branch to for for
prosecution and and candidly I I suspect
I mean you have to talk to somebody from
the county attorney's office about this
but I suspect that even if cases are
referred
um most of the time the County attorneys
will regard this as something of
relatively low priority in the overall
scheme of things you know the pro
prosecutor is going to be told okay
here's a case where there's an
allegation by one party that another
party has lied in some Court proceeding
um you know how important is this in the
overall scheme of things and I suspect
that many prosecutors would say you know
it's not all that important particularly
if it's not for lack of a better term a
sort of Slam Dunk if you if you actually
have a case where somebody has filed a
police report and then has admitted that
the police you know that it was it was
false sure that may make that may make
uh that may make a prosecutor more
inclined to want to move forward with it
um my suspicion is that there are not
all all that many cases so I I mean I I
think that I I guess I don't think that
this is Unworthy of looking into but in
terms of you know the prospect of of
having of of
uh coming up with a sort of better
solution I don't know I think I think we
would certainly have to have the
prosecutorial authorities involved in
this and maybe get getting them more
attuned or more willing to
uh uh to to prosecute those kinds of
cases I want to be responsive to the
people who have come to testify before
us when we had open hearings both here
and in children and family law that
we're taking the concern
seriously which may mean we have a
one-pager on Des describ
in what's next here's if you believe
that a perjury perjury has been
committed in your
case here's what you can do next here's
the standard you need to come up to
here's whom you call but something so
that the person believes he or she has
been taken seriously even if after that
it doesn't go anywhere I want them to
understand we are responsive I mean this
is the worst time in your life and we we
don't want to
be
insensitive now it may come to nothing
but I I I could just well maybe not but
I if if I were in this case I would want
to have something in front of me that if
I said your honor I think perjury has
been committed I would have something
that tells me here's what I do next
here's what I need to have in my hand
here's where I need to go here's what
we're not going to do about it right
here if the judge says even granted it
will not materially affect the outcome
of this C I need to have all that on one
page that would be a help I think to
some who
feel Justice isn't being
served um representative ball thank you
chairman Pearson and I don't know if
this is way off attorney krian you can
let me know if this would be way off
base because we know that it would be
very hard to prove that perjury or even
um giving a falsified police report
because when you write the police report
you may have believed that that's truly
what happened and after you think about
it it's like well maybe it didn't quite
happen that way I was emotional whatever
the
situation
um I don't know if it if it would be
appropriate and and more than likely it
wouldn't be but is there a way of
marking the file if so that we don't go
forward and the per other person may say
well you can't go forward with these
claims but somehow we could tag the file
to say that there was an indiscretion on
one part just so that we're aware that
it and the court or the future judge is
aware that something happened in the
past and we want to make sure that
everyone is above board and not
misrepresenting uh the truth um in the
future so I know what some judges do if
they think it isn't uncommon let's say
for example for for one parent to say I
took care of the child every time the
child was sick and the other parent says
I took care of the child at least half
the times they were sick and they both
think something very close to that is
the truth and the truth is maybe a
little bit in between um I don't think
that would be something that a Jud would
stand out to a judge because it's
understandable why someone would
misremember that a little bit um but
there are certainly instances where
someone says something in one hearing
and then says something that is clearly
different in not
reconcilable um in another and I think
some judges adopt a practice where they
put that in in an order um and they do
have that kind of noted particularly if
they think any records may have been
messed with um they note that and
sometimes they do if they think there's
pretty strong evidence that that
happened send it over to the county
attorney's office so they have the clerk
CC County attorney um some of those are
compelling to the county attorney
sometimes they're not but those are
instances where they can then flag on
the record if you look at exhibit 18
exhibit 22 you're going to see something
that might be of interest to you so you
do sometimes see judges do that but it
would not typically be for the case
where one parent remembers a little
differently how often they took care of
a child was sick because that's that's
human nature really that's probably not
deception on the part of either person
um a situation where records look like
they might have been messed with
completely contradictory testimony comes
in I think you do see judges try to put
that in orders um and forward it over so
that if it's persuasive to a county
attorney they might do something with it
and I did talk to One County attorney
from straford who told me he had charge
those sometimes he had been able to go
back in the records and see that the
person had entered two documents that
contradicted each other and that was a
charge Vice
chairman thank you I apologize for not
having my notebook with me today can you
refresh my uh memory as to roughly how
many cases a year um a family court
um
ballpark you know I I was ready for a
lot of questions I can tell you that
title D for 4D came in 1975 and it was
implemented in New Hampshire in
1985 uh but I have to tell you that
every time I come rep bford will turn to
me and say but what about the public
quarantine laws and I have not prepared
for that specific question and then it
feels I've really let him down there
would be no reason for you to have an
um but it is voluminous certainly let me
ask another one and if it's the same
answer I completely understand how many
uh family uh Court judges have um what I
as a lay person would call their own
clerk to keep track of records and um
take care of uh all the work that in
almost every Court in the United States
the budget writers listen carefully to
the answer please
uh we have about 44 judges that hear
family cases and three staff attorneys
that uh that cover any issues related to
the entire Circuit Court thank you so
that um if I could then even if the
number of cases that a family court
judge has is theoretically
manageable
um what is the
likelihood that a family court judge
working full-time on Family Court
matters is going to know and have the
time to uh record in an appropriately
Accurate Way um indications of the
possibility
unproven only alleged that they might
have been some
inaccuracies I I think that's a good
question um what what I used to say when
I was a a Fed every time the Congress
asked for something to be recorded I
said every question is $40,000 because
we have to hire someone to sift through
all the records and and look um for this
question to be answered and if it's five
questions then we need $200,000 to kind
of look through and answer every
question because I think sometimes
there's a VI that's very very easy to
have an extra box but there's a certain
amount of time over hundreds or even
thousands of cases that's associated
with that and then it has to be audited
to be sure it's correct um so it's it's
it's not easy to consistently track
things that there's not a business need
to track you of course track the
location you track the parties but you
may not track incidental features of the
case um but I do think and I think also
it's it's very very common for people to
disagree about the facts it's but it's
not so common that there is good
evidence um evidence that's noticeable
to a judge that they say this is
something this pleading and this other
pleading don't match and that's why in
the relatively few cases where it
happens a judge will have the thought
that I'll memorialize that in order but
to memorialize every instance in which a
person accuses another person of lying
and they may simply have different
memories would be a very big
lift thank you very much um if I could
just um without trying just take too
much time Mr chair I would like to go
back to the draft report that we have
prepared so far and suggest to you that
the these problems and many others could
be solved if number one we took the
committee's
suggestion um of more detailed training
and education for the judges number two
if we could find a way to make
clear that the
nominees uh for judges should be people
who have had professional
experience in the courts to which
they're going to be
assigned and those and similar uh steps
that we
recommended would address this in a much
more meaningful way than us trying to
figure out he says she says and I'd just
like to have us think about that a
little thank you Madam Vice chair all
right let's come to a
um conclusion on number two potential
ways to address
perjury remember we want to say to those
who have come before us we take your
concerns seriously we cannot revisit
your trial we are not an appell at court
but we can look at process and see if
the process might be um changed in any
way even if it is to
conclude we don't have any
recommendations at least we've looked at
it so uh I've asked representative Lynn
if he would be willing to chair this
subcommittee if there are sufficient
workers on it
um who here would be interested in
working with representative Lynn on this
subcommittee
all right representative Greg
representative ball representative
McMahon okay so I will constitute this
as a subcommittee with representative
Lynn chairing it we have representative
Greg ball and McMahon as members and
when I send out a followup on this
meeting there may be perhaps one or two
more and so we would be good to consider
whom should we be speaking with and what
do other states do on this subject has
this been looked at
before and um is this a worthy sub
chapter in the book y Dayan court that
we're all
writing thank you item number three on
the
list um that we might consider
researching impl
implications of implementing trial by
jury and family court which various
people testifying have uh
requested um I don't Prejudice the
outcome as to what this subcommittee
would
conclude but uh it may be worth it since
people have asked why don't we have this
if we conclude why indeed let's move
towards this or we may conclude in clude
because almost nobody else does it
because there's 15 reasons why we
shouldn't whatever the outcome is any
three I do yes representative long thank
you Mr chairman um so we're looking for
a jury that jury would be seated at
every hearing it could last for two
years 3 years four years how do we
change the jury
um I I think there's a reason why
they're
not
uh there's not a jury uh because of that
impation
um
okay
so anyone
else want to way
court uh I say I I most know what we do
in New Hampshire and and sometimes less
what's What's Done in other states but I
did study for this question um and I I
can tell you it is relatively rare I
think a a minority of states have jury
trial because of the traditional
division between law and equity in the
court system and what had a jury and
what would go to a court of equity Most
states follow the tradition that it it
is not a jury trial but there are
exceptions um and I think the exceptions
that you see are typically in single
instance highly fact-based
determinations so for example some
states have had jury determinations of
paternity that's less exciting now that
we have DNA testing but that used to be
something where credibility and fact
finding was potentially a very important
factor um there so and there for are
states that had fault divorce uh where
you were determining whether someone had
committed adultery something like that
um there there were cred credibility
determinations in fact finding that a
jury potentially was helpful with now
that more states have moved away from
fault divorce and now the paternity is
relatively easily established through
DNA I think you see it's a little less
common uh to have juries in a wide range
of procedures because of the problem
that families come to the courts
repeatedly for modifications of certain
types of orders you would not be able to
constitute that same jury you would have
to have a new jury each time um and even
in states that do have jury trials for
some issues they do not use them for
others so so for example when you're
looking at this issue you may find that
Texas is the absolute High Watermark of
number of questions in family law
submitted to a jury but there is still a
very large number of questions that they
do not want the jury weighing in on I
think division of property is one I
think only one state allows custody
determinations to be made with jury
input um so it is it is not extremely
common um but there are a couple states
that do it a few states that do it um
but they tend to focus on very factual
Vice chairman
Smith thank you
um am I completely
naive um I'm sure not I can't even wait
for the question to end well actually I
I wouldn't jump into it if I were you
because I could be completely naive
about this um I don't play lawyer on TV
and I never have um but I all I was
under the impression that
juries
determine facts and
judges
determine
law
and I see that as an important
difference is that is that
old-fashioned no ma'am uh that is
certainly correct that judges typically
make legal determinations judges do also
make factual determinations in a broad
range of circumstances jury in the
American system we don't have juries
ever making determinations of Law and
that's part of why even in the states
that have adopted juries for family
cases they still bifurcate the questions
of what the jury looks at and the
determination of ultimate legal issues
in a lot of cases um so even if you
decided to for example start with one
you might still say well the jury will
find who was telling the truth but the
court will make the property
determination or the court will make the
custody determination and I think that's
what you'd find that other states do as
well um but that doesn't mean courts and
judges can't find facts um you know the
typical historical division of the right
to jury trial has been where we had them
at in the courts of law at the time of
the founding of the United States which
is Criminal trials and certain types of
civil trials but not typically family
that do we wish to proceed in making a
subcommittee what's your
no
no I would say no
I can I
expand I I
yeah I I we will impanel them as yeah go
ahead to me it seems that the jury would
be more in a criminal court and unless
this was in a criminal situation um I
don't see a jury in Family
Court
Okay no Okay so we're not going to go
forward with
this maybe some other group at some
other
time um since we do have four proposals
that we started with and we have nine
members
um it would not be bad to limit the
number of projects subcommittees and so
on number four uh representative Greg
would you make your presentation please
this is four on the bottom of the hand
sure I'd be happy to and thank you Mr
chairman and I've talked to um attorney
krian about this particular case so I
had a constituent called that has had
guardianship for of her granddaughter
for um many years
um
and I suppose what they're supposed to
do according to the paper that I have is
have an email that's registered and I
did talk to um representative McBeth
yesterday at Great length about the
process of this because she's familiar
with these cases that in particular type
in guardianship cases they have gone to
electronic and not um paper so that
explained that a little bit further but
the um Guardian filed her uh filed her
paper in September and thought that she
probably didn't have to do anything for
another year the mother uh within 2
months later um filed to have the
guardianship um terminated had a hearing
the grandmother had not checked her
email so did not know any of this was
happening and found out that she had
lost the case by virtue of her not
protesting by the police knocking on the
door and saying they were taking the
little girl
immediately um which is pretty extreme
so I guess what I'm interested in and
I'm want to make sure that I'm focusing
on the right thing I do see the personal
responsibility element of knowing that
we need to check email if you've been
told that and actually I have the um
motion to terminate guardianship that
I've redacted uh with any pertinent
things but it does say on there that
they had to the email address that all
interested parties are required to keep
and monitor um but also what happen you
know what that does to that little girl
when they just show up if there has not
if this has been a guardian that has
been commuted to communicative is all of
a sudden not communicative um and then
we're just going to take custody of a
little girl who's been in there for I
think over seven years with her
grandmother and going to stay with her
mother who she's not seen now for most
of the year what does that process look
like and is there anything that were
kind of missing in there that um that we
would you know are the judges doing
anything like oh we haven't heard from
this person do we give them a heads up
and maybe I think that um repres that uh
attorney KGAN has looked into it so
put hello uh thank you for bringing that
case to our attention um because these
are confidential cases I'm just going to
speak hypothetically the constituent is
totally free to discuss it with her
representative but I as a court system
person have to be a little bit careful
but um we we did do a review and I think
there is room for improvement here um I
can say that very few circuit court case
types have been transitioned over to
electronic and guardianship is one of
those case types and mostly people
people prefer to use their email rather
than mail but that's not without some
unanticipated consequences and there can
certainly be a case where a person gets
Court email and for some reason it goes
to their junk folder um and they don't
see it um there was there is a process
generally in place for guardianship
cases where if the email bounces back a
letter is sent I think our view is that
in light of learning this we need to
also send a mail letter when the email
is not read um which we do have the
ability to go in and check uh but that
would only respond to this one
particular case and I think we can make
that change in our procedures and we and
we see that there's room to do this
better I also referred this question
over to our community engagement and
access committee because I think there's
a broader question about expanding
electronic case types in Circuit Court
where people are very used to them being
male and whether there are any
unanticipated consequences and I don't
think we this is one example of one
consequence but I want to I think we
want to look into whether they're
potentially others um
because attorneys if an attorney is
using their Law Firm email they are
checking that email always they do not
have messages from the court going to
their spam folder um but that could
happen with a private citizen so I we I
think there's there's learning as we
expand in case types where most people
are self are presented um to email
notification and that's that's something
we're reviewing but I think this
uh does show us that there was a
procedure change that we needed to make
that if an email was not opened we also
needed to send a physical letter um but
there may be others and if you hear
anything from your constituents from
anyone anyone who's on YouTube um you
know send a letter to the AOC or email
is online or send it to me because uh we
we do want to know uh we do want to fix
procedures that are not working for
people would you find it helpful if a
subcommittee uh were to meet with you
and perhaps a few others from
Judiciary uh to examine this issue I I
defer to you but I would encourage
anyone whether they're a member of this
sub committee or not to reach out
because we want to know when things are
not working for the people the course
that is the gracious way in which you
have interacted with us thus far I just
want to
check anyone representative Lynn so can
I just raise a question is um am I
correct in understanding that if if
someone is starting a lawsuit in other
words the very
first F the very first filing that that
the notice of that to the
defendant does not come does not go
through email it would go there would
have to be serviced by the sheriff or
whatever is that correct it depends on
the case type what types of services are
accepted but it it can be male service
it can be serviced by the sheriff um so
it it's particular something other than
email though is that correct so I guess
the thing I'm a little curious about is
it um it seems
like although the mother filed this
motion to terminate the guard it it was
would seem to me that is almost
like you know a new proceeding that
should have resulted in kind of more
formal notice um uh may maybe not by the
sheriff but at least you know a
certified letter or something like that
that would really kind of get the
attention of the person that's a great
question there are some statutory
requirements when you sort of reopen or
refresh a case that there is a reservice
there was not that requirement for this
case type um so so that does happen in
some family cases but but not for this
one we could make changes to our rules
it doesn't necessarily have to be a
statutory change but I think that's what
you're thinking of is that family cases
that have been dormant for a long time
they often are reopened by a reservice
right that's required and that was not a
requirement for this case type okay all
right anyone else
yes Madam Vice
chair could you help me understand why
it would be police officers going to a
house to take a child who obviously had
not committed any act that was contrary
to the law rather than uh trained social
workers and I'm using that as a general
term that I do not have information
about representative I apologize I don't
know why it would be a police officer
being
involved thank
you representative ball thank you
chairman
Parson I guess I'm still old school
so sorry that's old school that's old
school new
school um so it seems sending a police
well not to get the child but the
paperwork um in servicing and all why
are we not using just certified maale to
assure and especially in a case that
involves child custody is becoming in
question it just seems to me the easiest
thing to do is require certified
male you know where the address is and
if that certified mail comes back to you
that's a red flag that we better get
there right away because this person has
a child um you know that they are
responsible for and they obviously may
not be at that address anymore so I'm
just wondering why did we stray away
from old school and go to something
where we still have people
um in our society that are not using
email um in the way that um some other
people are using it that might be more
professional people but those of us in
the older Generation Um may not
recognize that thanks that's a great
question one of the most consistent
pieces of feedback we receive from the
public is the desire to transition cases
over to have more email uh use um and we
do get complaints the other way people
are really struggle to update the court
when they change their mailing address
um it's a very consistent issue that
people just do not remember you think of
all the things you have to change when
you change your address you inevitably
Miss some every time I move I miss some
people miss the court um so people Miss
very important filings by mail all the
time and so some folks have indicated to
us that they use the same email their
whole life that would be easier for them
um so we we do get different feedback
from different people
followup could we not use both systems
continue with the certified mail which
is what5 or $7 or whatever it is and
still send a notice as well just to make
sure that we're covering both bases
especially since a child um is involved
in
this I think for it's a determination
that there there are statutory
components so certainly the legislature
can adjust some of them but for some
regular notifications you may not find
that that's necessary um but because in
the same way that there's reservice in
certain family cases this may be
something where you determine that
reservice is appropriate for certain
kinds of motions in a guardianship case
rules yes
welcome um thank you for um taking the
question didn't you say I think you said
something that the Court can check and
see whether an email has been opened so
um is that is that correct and is that's
a procedure that you all could change
Within
um without speaking on a particular case
I can say when I generally looked into
this issue I found that we did have the
ability to see that when someone had not
opened their email I don't know if it's
foolproof or maybe there's certain types
of emails where it's easier than others
but we generally do and so our thought
of the easiest change to make was to
mail if we had an unread um email on an
important
followup I I so I've actually would you
believe had um a clerk's office call
seeing that I had not opened something
that had gone to my spam or that I had
missed and realizing that either I
hadn't submitted a report or that it
wasn't open and something was coming up
so but again that that can't be
something that we always require but I
think it probably is happening in some
cases and I mean this is that's a really
sorry Case um I also will say that some
attorneys I do my mail goes to spam if I
file in a court that I haven't filed in
recently like a superior court or
something like that so I think the spam
idea I mean that that's it is if you all
can check if that is when people don't
open their mail it's it's probably not
just the public although I know I know
because it's happened I mean that's why
I mean I'm familiar with it so I know to
check spam as what that's good to know
because we we often don't hear um so
that I appreciate that feedback that's
good to know that that's a broader
problem representative ball thank you
chairman Parson um it's my understanding
that email can also be sent with with a
receipt uh requested so it could be as
easy as just starting to send things out
receipt requested that way you would
have a um a paper trail thank
you the question since I am struggling
to learn email and didn't know about
this until just now is there a receipt
sent when they open the email or when it
lands in their
inbox chairman parison I believe it's
when they open it it confirms that they
have received it and they have they've
opened it is that
this that's good thank you you got to
learn how to do
that anyone
else okay good thank you um who' like to
be on this subcommittee representative
Greg I have asked that if we get a few
people to work with her this can be a
subcommittee and she can share it who
else what I already signed up for a
couple of committees but I do think this
is a very important committee and if you
need another person um I would be happy
to help but I do think that you are in
good hands um working within the
Departments no one is accusing you of
being greedy I know just to let you know
I do think that's extremely
important yeah this this email will go
out to representative katab uh to see
where she would like to slot in
um and we'll give a last few minutes I
know a couple people uh thank you for
coming uh got here late but thank you
for coming take a look at the handout
sheet and see item number one to review
it's research title four we questioned
how does this have to do with family
court subsection D child support aspect
of it is in the courts so uh number one
is something we could
do
um item number two has to do with the
ways to address perjury we looked at
some possibilities but at least to come
up with an explanations of why the court
does what it does so people who are
wondering would
have an answer I think everyone was here
for three we said no to that we would
just here for four if there's anybody
else who wishes to um uh sign up for one
and two uh
mcbath give you a few minutes to read it
no not a different one perhaps an
additional one there are three
committees and you can number two um
you're also on number four and that's
okay that would be possible too thank
you
um Greg ball
McMahon and Lynn sounds like a la for
hm you are right
here I'm on the
ball uh anything else from
representative mcmah you're on number
two do you wish to be on one and or four
or neither neither okay you're on number
two that's good
long so so um running for Senate I
understand
H you're running for
Senate it's in the paper so it's got to
be
true okay so you're going to be all full
up
but you will
no it's hard work to say no I know oh
and I have to practice I know I'm trying
very when are you going to start doing
that like next November maybe I'm
practicing
now
okay after I mean who knows I might I
don't know if I'll have a primary I
might lose then I'd have a lot of time
on my hand but
otherwise I don't
okay then I think we're done um I will
be in touch with
representative um Tab and if you could
send those notes out I'll talk to you
about that and uh all comment if I make
what's that a
comment what's that again a comment can
I make a comment yeah go ahead
representative long yeah just on uh on
uh item number four yeah uh if you could
also look at I I've gotten calls from
foster parents who've had a child taken
where they didn't realize that child was
going to be taken um so just on
uh look at the overall disposition of
children that are moving from Foster
Care to foster care or uh or like the
case uh the Guardian case also just
any
any issues that we've heard on children
being removed where the adults that were
responsible weren't made aware of that
is that through the court C or through
the through HH yes uh I believe it in in
a couple cases that I heard uh the
foster parents it's been through that
HHS has has uh gone over not necessarily
a police officer so although you are not
going to be an actual member of the sub
committee you are offering your services
as the occasional consultant oh
absolutely I I I could build up that
responsibility for item four okay so um
I will put this in lowercase letter
okay and that is the long and short of
it very good you're welcome oh that was
not you could do better than that I have
the chairman I know but on we need the
long ball answer on this okay thank you
it's a
stretch anyone else from the committee
okay seeing none I adjourn the um work
session on this and uh we will get you
the minutes from today at some point
and I will send out a uh an email on uh
the
Committees uh when you go thank you as
welcome
Miss
e